and the dramatic advance of ukraine's
army causing something we rarely see in
russia public displays of anger
ukrainian troops here's why have
recaptured an estimated 2 000 square
miles of territory in recent days and
the country president the country's
president says that counter-attack is
going to continue back in russia
meanwhile putin is now facing rare
criticism at home deborah patta has the
latest now from harkeev in the
northeastern part of the country where
russian troops have effectively been
forced out
seizing the momentum ukrainian troops
continue their remarkable advance yellow
and blue pretty much the only colors
flying high across this region today as
they win the admiration of liberated
towns and villages
our troops were so smart said this woman
the russian soldiers ran away so fast
they planned this really well
when vladimir putin declared war on
ukraine nearly seven months ago his
troops seized massive chunks of haqqiv
but in just a matter of days ukrainian
forces have blitzed through russia's
gains snatching back huge swaths of land
it's a crushing defeat and a decisive
strike against moscow's ability to
resupply their forces now they can no
longer use liberated izum as a strategic
hub
they left all their explosives and
ammunition here said this ukrainian
soldier
as the russian front line collapsed
the extent of a war declared largely on
civilians is becoming clear hospitals
and schools blown up people killed in
their own backyards
away from the battlefield hard questions
for putin on state-run television which
usually only pushes moscow's line in its
so-called special military operation
it's either full-scale war or we get out
said former parliamentarian baris
nadeshton and policy expert victor
olivich exclaimed in disbelief
you say everything's going according to
plan you really think six months ago we
planned on leaving and repelling a
counter-offensive
ukrainians want to believe that the tide
is turning in a war that's been weighted
in russia's favor but secretary of state
anthony blinken warned that while the
counter-offensive was well planned and
had clearly benefited from western
military aid it was too early to predict
an outcome gail
all right that's one way to look at it
thank you very much deborah powder
reporting from ukraine